it might seem at first glance as though
the people we term high achievers could
not possibly require our sympathy or
compassion after all they are the ones
who did exceptionally well in exams whom
the teachers admired who won places at
the best universities
who graduated with honours who got into
law and medical schools who founded
thriving businesses who live in the
wealthiest parts of town who were up
early in the morning preparing
themselves healthy breakfasts before a
day of important meetings surely we
can't suggest that these might be
victims
except of course that it would rarely
occur to anyone who did not harbor a
high degree of self-suspicion to
undertake so many outsized efforts to
impress and to make a mark upon the
world
the high achievers for all their
accomplishments
cannot trust in a basic idea
that it might be acceptable to be
themselves
outside of any acclaim notice or
distinction
simply being is never enough their right
to exist can only be assured by constant
doing
their frantic activity masks an
underlying unquenchable doubt as to
their acceptability
it may have been many years since they
enjoyed a day without commitments
the moment that they are at a loose end
anxiety arises
what are they meant to be doing
what have they forgotten to take care of
do they have the right to be still
no one can doubt what we owe to the high
achievers
they are the ones who build the
skyscrapers who explore distant planets
who drive the stock market to new
heights who start businesses and write
films and books
we would all be the poorer without them
but our respect shouldn't rob us of our
ability to appraise the costs that their
ways of life exact the wealth of nations
is built upon the troubles of the
individual psyche
the high achievers have been driven to
act not simply from talent or creativity
energy and skill
though these are no doubt present as
well
but from a primordial sense that there
is something shameful about them in
their basic state
and that they must hence clothe
themselves in the garments of success to
escape the humiliation of their true
selves
no wonder that their efforts are so
often self-defeating
it may for a long time seem as if they
were after money power acclaim and
distinction but these are merely
substitutes for their fundamental but
unknown goal
a sense of basic adequacy
the
explains the curious sadness that may
accompany high achievers at some of
their moments of greatest triumph
finally they have sold the company
at last they have won an international
prize but they are likely to feel hollow
in the days and years that follow
as they confusedly recognize that every
possible achievement has been gained but
none of it has somehow been sufficient
to quell the pain and restlessness
within
it can be counted as close to good
fortune if high achievers stumble and
fail somewhere along their journey
if they are tripped up by an unexpected
bankruptcy scandal or economic downturn
the reversal may prompt a mental
breakdown and a period of rest in which
there is a slither of hope for it
contains a chance to see that their
manic pursuit of success was all along
masking a terror about unlovability
which now has a chance to be quelled in
a more realistic and effective way
there is an opportunity to acknowledge
that one has been playing the wrong game
all along
and that the true problem never had
anything to do with a lack of prizes
and everything to do with a burning
conviction that one might need so many
of them
it is a measure of our collective
delusion that we are so ready to be
proud of high achievers
and so slow to detect the wound that
powers them on
it would be a less gilded world but also
a far happier one in which we were
readier to reassure the self-hating
titans of success
that they were worthy of love all along
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more